Hi everybody. This is Godad for the sad
truth. It's been a while since my uh
last chat on the show because I've been
traveling extensively. But today I have
a guest that I've known of him for many
years and uh unfortunately I had yet to
invite him but I have corrected this
grave error by inviting Raymond Ibraim
on the show. How are you doing sir?
>> Hello Gad. Good to be with you. uh look
forward to the our conversation because
I I think I told you you're one of the
most people who people always tell me I
should talk with you. So I think there's
a lot of uh synratism going on between
us.
>> Exactly. Uh so I'm going to just
introduce you first then I'm going to
break out some Arabic so that people
know that you can't delegitimize us
because we don't speak Arabic and we're
not from the region and we don't
understand true Islam and so on. So you
are the distinguished senior Shilman
fellow at the Gatesstone Institute. They
do great work and the Judith Freriedman
Rosen fellow at the Middle East Forum.
You have many books written. I'll start
with your most recent ones and work
backwards. You have a fourthcoming book,
The Two Swords of Christ, Five Centuries
of War between Islam and the Warrior
Monks of Christ Christianom coming in
November. Yes.
>> Correct.
>> Right. Then we've got in 2022 defenders
of the west the Christian heroes who
stood against Islam and in 2018 uh sword
and scimitar for which is a type of
sword 14 centuries of war between Islam
and the west then in 2013 crucified
again exposing Islam's new war on
Christians 2007 the alqaaida reader and
then your master's thesis and there's
actually a link between your master's
thesis and yours truly you'll notice
Second, why the battle of Yarmmuk, which
was a very important battle in this in
early Islam in the 7th century, an
assessment of the immediate factors
behind the Islamic conquests. Is there
anything you'd like to add to this bio
before we get going?
>> Uh, no. Those are my main books. Yeah.
>> Okay, perfect. Uh, so let me first I'm
I'm going to get to the Arabic in a
second, but let me Can you guess what
might be the link between your master's
thesis and something of mine? It's hard
to
>> Are you Are you somehow from the region
of Yarmmuk?
>> Well, I'm certainly from the I'm
certainly from the general
>> in Syria, but yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly. I I do have Syrian
ancestor grandparents. No, it's actually
and I didn't know this until I was doing
my homework on your bio. Your supervisor
is the uh glorious Victor Davis Hansen.
Yes.
>> Right. Now this is from this is from
sorry don't mean to plug my own book
here but this is from my last book my
latest book the sad truth about
happiness I want to read you page 193
which is towards the end of the book I
recently held a chat on my show with the
classicist and military historian Victor
Davis Hansen as we were saying our
goodbyes Victor ended our conversation
with the following quote thank you and
it's so nice to see an academic who
smiles I don't do it enough but you do.
Close quote. So, is that true? Was he as
non-smiley and da as when you knew him
way back in the day?
>> Yeah, I think so. Um, actually, the kind
of the guy that you see on TV is very
much similar to the guy he is behind the
scenes. Maybe a little more jaded and
somewhat cynical, I suppose. But, uh,
yeah, not necessarily with the biggest
grin.
>> Right. Exactly. Uh,
>> he's an old farmer. He is an old
actually that's one of the things that I
love and respect most about him because
he's able to navigate I mean I think he
calls it the the musculature class uh
right so he's able to both be brun as
you seem to be in very good shape and
muscular and we can both have a a mind
and be athletic and physical and
hardwork with our hands and so I I
respect that. Okay. I want to say a few
words to you in Arabic.
Huh? Shr.
So I asked first I said it's it's a
pleasure to meet you. And then I said as
you probably know there's always battles
in terms of who's got the best food,
who's got the best hummus, who's got the
best accent. And so often people say
that the two most beautiful Arabic
accents are the Lebanese one and the
Egyptian one. And so I asked Raymond
which is the more beautiful one, the
Arab the Lebanese or the Egyptian. He
said of course I'm going to say Egyptian
because he's Egyptian Coptic Christian.
So maybe we could start there.
>> And and because
so
>> and because uh Egypt is the center the
mother of the world. So there you go,
>> as Egyptians love to say.
>> Exactly. Uh well, first of all, you
maybe just tell us a bit about your your
background. You were born in Egypt or in
the United States.
>> I was born in the United States. My
parents immigrated here uh in the late
60s. I was born in um 73. And um yeah,
and I so I grew up uh with this sort of
rare ability of being um bilingual
because at outside I was speaking
English and at home I was speaking
Arabic. Um and you know that's one of
the main reasons of course you can
imagine that sort of um made me
interested in the topics that I've
definitely gravitated towards being a
Christian from the Middle East who grew
up in the west and who sees the ongoing
threats of Islam both here and there
obviously weighed on me and so even back
in the days with Victor Davis Hansen as
you saw my battle of Yarmmuk that was my
thesis which he was the um the the chief
the chair the adviser and so and that
was actually being written right before
9/11 in 2001. one I was finishing it up.
It actually was published I think right
before it and um that's really what sort
of catapulted me into this career
>> because I was I was completely into the
academic historical side and I've never
really been into modern politics and um
I had just finished it and then 911
happened and then much later fast
forward I'm at the Library of Congress
we could talk about that and I come
across writings in Arabic by bin Laden
and Aman Zwahi al-Qaeda which I
translated in my in my book the al-Qaeda
reader but what I was reading is they
were actually citing all the battles
that uh they were talking about the
battle of Yarmmuk. They were they were
using the same rationale of the guys
that I was writing about in the 7th
century and which I as a good college
student had been told was antiquated
thinking. Nobody thinks that way
including Muslims anymore. And so that's
what grabbed my attention initially
reading how on the one hand CNN and BBC
and these people were relaying the
communicates of al-Qaeda which was all
about grievances, right? we hit you, you
hit us, you support Israel, um you know,
colonialism, crusades, they said it all.
It was always a grievance and they
posited their retaliation as just that,
retaliation, not aggression. But then
the writings that Bin Laden and Zahiri
wrote to Muslims in Arabic, which CNN
and BBC did not relay, and I did in my
book, said the exact opposite. They
sounded like ISIS. They were quoting the
battle of Yarmmuk. we're talking about
jihad against the infidel irrespective
of if they do good to you or bad to you
has nothing to do with grievances they
need to be laid low etc etc so that's I
think what really got me you know it
helped me cross the bridge from having
sort of an academic interest in the
history and doctrine of Islam to just
seeing how totally applicable it was in
the now and on the other hand how
everyone was telling us it's not
>> that there was no continuity that you
know this has and then a later problem
which we can get into is even history
was so corrupted now even the historical
presentation of Islam was not what it
was what I knew it was as I had read it
in these primary sources so that's um
you know that's uh so to give you a long
story short about who I am after after
that I went to Georgetown University the
the center of contemporary Arab studies
and again I'm still naive I'm in my 20s
>> world right
>> yes yes and he was there when I was
there and I had no idea about, you know,
the pol the politics and political
correctness. And I got in a little I got
all A's, but I got in a lot of trouble
because I would ask the questions you're
not supposed to ask. And I remember
offending a professor V O L and he just
got really angry and I mean anyway, long
story short, I ended up actually I got a
job at the Library of Congress in the
Middle Eastern division. That's where I
came across the Arabic writings and I
ended up just dropping from Georgetown
because I didn't want to deal with it.
And um anyway uh then I found the book
and I continued working there and then
long story short by 2008 2009 I started
becoming a fellow at various think tanks
um Middle East forum later on the Hoover
Institute you know and then the
Gatesstone Institute and basically from
2009 I've just been a writer primarily
of books and articles the books that you
mentioned and probably 2,500 articles in
that time frame and most recently I'm
trying to be a YouTuber.
So, I'm actually on the show.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Thank you. So, I'm I'm
trying to I've finally given in and
realized that um to reach the younger
generations and maybe even the older
ones, this is the medium to go videos
because people are more, you know, in
tune with watching than reading. So, I'm
happy to oblige.
>> Well, look, uh first, thank you for that
great sort of summary of your career,
but uh I hate it, maybe just because I'm
a professor, I hate it when I hear that
a student has dropped out. Is there
anything that I can say that can get you
to go back and finish that damn PhD or
that's in the rearview mirror never to
be uh you know gone over again?
>> You mean me personally?
>> Yes, you personally.
>> Well, I'll tell you why I did it. First,
it was it was a practical reason. I had
a full the full-time job at the Library
of Congress, you know, which was I mean
and I lived in that area and the commute
and the work was like 12 hours of my day
essentially. And then I had the book
project, the al-Qaeda reader, which was
a major book deal. Uh, it was it was
reported all over the media. Um, and so
I was committed to that. And I was, and
then the most important point, and
Victor Davis Hansen actually told me
this. We had to talk about my future
career. And he was like, you got you
already got what most people who when
they try to get a PhD want, right? Okay.
You got a major book deal, and this was
a big book deal, and you work at the
Library of Congress, and you're probably
and and you can write what you want to
write. And the second thing is because
you're doing what you're doing and
writing what you're writing, even if you
got your PhD, they're not going to hire
you because
>> But hold on. But as we know from Middle
Eastern parents, your you've removed the
possibility of your parents showing off
to all of their friends by introducing
you as doctor.
>> What are you doing, Raymond? Why are you
so selfish to your parents?
>> I would agree, but they've both passed
on, so it's it's not applicable at this
point. May May God redeem them. Uh,
okay. So, let's get into
>> I was going to do some other stuff, but
I want to just get into the Islamic
doctrines. One of the things that I
explained to people for for many many
decades now, and of course, it's
fantastic to have a guest such as
yourself here to kind of discuss these
things.
Whether it be the battle of Yarmmuk or
any other expansionist projects of Islam
that stems from the duality in Islam of
having Darab and D Islam the the house
or the salon of Islam which is that's
under dominion of Islam and any other
land that is yet to be unified under the
unifying flag of Allah is really in the
house of war and any land that Islam
conquers and then it loses it has to
canonically get back hence we will
inshallah get back El and Lucia anything
you want to add to that anything you
want to expand on because people don't
understand that that is one of the most
fundamental precepts of Islam
>> yeah um first I agree completely what
you said that is indeed the sort of um
dichotomy of how Islam sees the world
but I also have I think a nifty way of
helping people understand it in a in a
sort of you know downto-earth way I
always say that the genius if you will
of Muhammad is that he took tribalism
which was endemic to 7th century Arabia
and he rearticulated it through a
theological paradigm which made it
everlasting and much more powerful. So
what I mean is as you know tribalism is
which all peoples most of them had it
historically it's it's basically us
against you that's it you are the enemy
because you're not a blood kin of mine
you're my enemy brothers are closer and
they'll fight cousins and then the
brothers and the cousins will fight
together against you know so it's that
mentality
and and I don't think people understand
but to be outside the tribe means
essentially to be non-human you are free
game if I you're not part of my tribe I
kill you I enslave you I do whatever
Okay. And that was the world that
Muhammad grew in. And if you look at the
the Quran and some of the teachings,
especially the one known as right, which
you can translate, I often do it as
loyalty and enmity or even more simply
love and hate, allegiance, disleiance
according to that. So Muhammad basically
took the idea of tribalism but changed
it. So now it was no longer blood kin.
It was the believers, the um whoever is
part of Islam is are my tribe member and
whoever is outside of it is the enemy is
the non-tribal fellow. And one of the
reasons that I found through my
historical studies that really supports
this is that all the peoples who
actually converted to Islam in mass were
tribal people. Okay? So first of course
the Arabs, later on the Berbers of North
Africa, the Turks and then the Mongols.
Later you know groups of Mongols did
become Islamic and all of those people
lived according a tribal principle. And
if you look at uh one of the oral
they're they're written down later, but
the or early oral traditions of the
Turks Di Corut is the book and they and
they and they have them kind of like you
have what they thought before they
became Muslim and then you have when
they had just become Muslim and when
right before they become Muslim they're
talking about I killed the you know the
whatever word they use for the
non-tribal you know the enemy and I took
his pretty girls and I burned down his
home. Now they become Muslim and all of
a sudden it's in the name of Allah I
killed the infidel and I took and I
burned his church. Okay. So it was the
same exact thinking but it was now
repackaged through a divine paradigm
which made it so much more potent
because now it's what I call a win-win
scenario. Before if it's just tribalism
you fight you you win you blunder or you
die. Now you fight you win and you
plunder you win. And if you die you go
to heaven and you win again because now
you got the 72 virgins and pure bliss.
Okay. So I think uh that's the enduring
legacy of Muhammad's genius if you will
is that he just completely rearticulated
tribalism and he just gave it this
powerful mold through deification. And
that's kind of why it's it's spilled
into the modern era and it's not going
to go away anytime soon. And uh to your
point about you know Muhammad's very
earthly psychology if you'd like I think
it was Aisha and you'll correct me if
I'm wrong who said something to the
effect you know oh you know uh prophet
of God it seems quite befitting how you
always seem to get revelations that are
in your interest or something to that
effect.
>> Yeah. So tell us about that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, that's, you know, I'm
I'm I'm something I'm in a debate right
now with um one J. Smith, Dr. J. Smith,
who's, you know, this chief proponent
that Muhammad didn't exist. That theory
and what you what you're touching on, it
just reminds me again, you know, it's
one more proof that Muhammad exists is
because when you really look at the
Islamic scriptures, they're so
unflattering, but they really capture a
real person, right?
>> When you read between the lines, you
know, if it was fake, it should be
polished and nice and wow, this guy is
just perfect. But when you read between
the lines, you get like what you're
saying, which is basically his young
child bride, Aisha. Uh Muhammad, as we
know, he gets revelations, right? And
these become the Quran. And one of them,
it was always convenient. So when he's
in a pickle, and all of a sudden he's I
got a revelation from Gabriel. And this
one was about, I think, how he need he,
as opposed to most Muslims who get four
wives could marry more.
>> Exactly.
Or or when his son-in-law's wife is
really pretty,
>> he gets a revelation that he should go
with her.
>> Exactly. Yeah.
>> It's like I mean, God, who is the ruler
of an infinite universe that as far as
we know so far is 16 billion light years
in sort of its territory is able to
exactly cater to an individual's,
you know, desires, appetites. It's
amazing. I think it's beautiful.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, that it's Yeah. And um
I mean and there's so much more. We can
talk about that if you want to go down
that, but I'll leave it to you.
>> Okay. So, uh
for almost 30 years now, maybe even a
bit more. I've been a professor for 31
years. I've been trying given my
background
and knowledge on in the area to try to
warn the West. Right. Just like you did
post I think you said 9/11. you started
getting involved and so on. Uh in our in
our unique ways, we've both been
pursuing a parallel strategy of saying,
"Hey guys, here are some issues that you
might want to worry about in the West."
Regrettably, I say this, I'm I'm a very,
as your former supervisor said, I'm a
I'm a very optimistic person. I'm a very
happy person. But yet, after three
decades of trying to stand on top of the
mountain and scream about the looming
dangers, I I mean, sure, I've changed a
lot of minds, but those who are coming
seem to be coming at a much faster rate
than I can change minds. Am I being too
pessimistic, Raymond? Can you give us
some optimism? Or am I exactly right
that we are doomed?
>> What I'll give you is more pessimism
actually than what you even said. uh
because I completely agree with you and
I'm going to give you a very modern-day
example that completely validates what
you're saying. So, you and I have been
at this for a while. You know, my first
article was published in 20 years ago,
right around 2005 for the LA Times. And
since then, I've been writing and
spelling out the dangers of Islam, etc.,
etc. Okay, now here's here look now,
let's move on to Syria and look at
what's happening to the Drews. Okay. And
it's just I I'm sure you know it's just
so I've been watching some of these
videos and they're just beyond horrific
what they do. I saw a video of a man
tied down. They burn him alive screaming
Allah Akbar. They show they they throw
him off roofs. They cut a woman. They
raped her, cut her tongue out and then
like and wrote and then with a knife
carved a Quranic verse on her breasts.
Really disgusting and horrific stuff.
And in almost every case they're
screaming Allah Akbar. But here's the
problem, you know? It's like we've seen
this time and time again and it always
comes from the same exact recipes.
You're going to put Muslim
fundamentalists who believe what they
believe. Um I just I just tweeted or put
on XA you know Islamya
his fatwa against the um Drews which is
basically lay them low, destroy them,
kill them, rape them. Okay, that's what
he says on principle and there's no
chance for them to even convert because
they're zanadikah and mortaden which as
you know they're hypocrites and
apostates they're the lowest of the low
and
is taught all throughout the Islamic
world in alazar and so forth. So I'm not
shocked to see that when you put people
who take Islam seriously like the new
Syrian government and you put this
infidel minority that they're going to
butcher them. And the thing is though,
isn't this always the case? If you go
way back as far back as Reagan and all
the way to Trump, Democrat, Republican,
we are always siding with Islamic
terrorists and empowering them and then
this happens. Okay? I we can go into I
mean I did a whole study a long time ago
about Obama and how he meddled in the
Islamic world and etc etc and all and
wherever they meddled and and I
mentioned Reagan of course because he
used to support the support the
mujahedin which became al-Qaeda right
and it just never fails and and everyone
thought well Donald Trump's different
and Donald Trump comes and calls this
man Ahmed al- Shar who's actually
al-Qaeda remember the ones who killed
3,000 Americans he shakes his hand and
praises him I quoted him recently. I
know this guy's a tough guy. I think
he's going to give Syria a new chance.
And lo and behold, the same thing that
happened a decade ago, which is
ISISminded guys are slaughtering
Yazidis. Remember that? Here it's
happening again. So, it just seems to me
that no matter what we say, what we do,
it's just like a a machine that is not
going to stop and is not going to
change. And and I'm even I'm starting to
get tired of even describing like what's
happening to the Drews. It's taking on a
voyeristic quality. It's almost like all
we want to do is oh look at the horrible
things and we ring our hands and hashtag
until tomorrow the news tells us to talk
and be angry about this thing and we
forget you know so it's it's just uh as
you can see more than you and Victor I'm
quite appalled and and really jaded
about the whole thing because it just
it's and it doesn't even matter at this
point if US leadership or western
leadership in general is naive or
diabolical because it's the same result
in the end. You always have wherever
they go, Muslim terrorists come to power
and innocents get killed and then
eventually the jihadists turn on bite
the hand that fed them and attack the
US, Europe via 911, etc., etc. So that's
my little spiel there.
>> Well, so uh one of the things that uh so
I I don't know if you're familiar with
one of my earlier books, the parasitic
mind. The parasitic mind looked at what
happens to human minds when they are
parasitized by idea pathogens. So what
happens when to your mind when it is
hijacked right and then in my
forthcoming book suicidal empathy I
complete the story by saying well what
happens to your emotional system when it
is hijacked right so so su so so empathy
could be uh gained uh to your detriment
to your suicidal detriment and it seems
to me that somehow the west has
succumbed to both parasitic thinking and
suicidal empathy and so let let me take
some of the things that you mentioned
Oh, 9/11. Oh, well, 9/11 was really
caused by the Jews. Okay. I try to
engage someone and it's absolutely
impenetrable. I cannot get through the
fact that it wasn't the dirty Jews who
did it. If you show me videos of the
Drews being slaughtered, those are not
uh first of all, they're not true
Muslims, right? So, that's the constant
thing we hear, right? My friend Ahmed
who is gay, eats proh and is married to
a Jewish man. He represents true Islam.
Whereas uh you know Alzari,
is that his name? What's his name?
>> The Egyptian one or the
>> Egyptian one.
>> Zawahi or the guys at Al Ahar or Ysef
Karadawi or the Al Bakdadi or any of
those guys, none of them represent true
Islam. Saudi Arabia doesn't represent
true Islam. the the moolas in in Iran
don't represent Islam because my Islamic
store owner at the convenience store is
a lovely guy. He's never hurt anyone. As
a matter of fact, he always comes to our
synagogue. So there is really, it seems
to me, a frailty in the architecture of
the human mind that makes it perfectly
aligned with Islam coming in. Because if
you look at the battle of Yarmmuk or any
other battle that has ever existed
throughout human history, there is a
clear set of rules. We live on this side
of the river, you live on that side of
the river. We want your women, you want
ours. Let's fight and see who wins. It's
a whole new ball game. When one side of
the river says, "We don't fight. You
guys are glorious. Please have at our
children and our women. Take it away."
Hence, suicidal is
>> That's Europe today.
>> That's Europe today. That's Canada
today. That's US tomorrow, inshallah.
So, so is there any vaccine? I mean, I
try to develop mind vaccines, but I feel
as though I'm losing the battle. Is
there any mind vaccine that you could
think of that can autocorrect this or
are we really just going through a slow
eventual demise, whether it be in 50
years or 500 years?
>> Well, you touch on a really important
point, which is, you know, a lot of
people think that facts and and making
the correct argument and proving your
point is enough. And unfortunately, it's
not because of psychological and
emotional reasons that you mentioned
that people cling to. And so, I think
that um you know, the only remedy is uh
things will get worse before they can
get better. You know, there's that I'm
sure you're familiar with this saying
something like strong men create good
societies and good societies create weak
men, weak men, you know, weak societies
until the society breaks down, then
strong men rise again. So unfortunately
that may be the case that it's just
going to when I look you know what
you're talking about and when I look at
Europe and Canada and these and these
places I've never seen any who has ever
seen something where one group of people
have a history and a doctrine that hates
you and they make no qualms about hiding
it. They're constantly saying it and
then the other group goes out of their
way to bring them in and and if then
other and then then the citizens and
native citizens the native Europeans
notice and complain because their people
are being raped and killed then you shut
them down. Okay? I mean this is what
what madness is this? I mean you say
it's suicidal parasitic. It's all that
and more. You know what I mean? And and
I don't know again you know the big
question is this intentional? Is this
naivity? again, doesn't really matter if
they're fools or liars. It's the same
end result that people have to deal
with. And I mean, I think we're at a
point now where it just does the the old
the model's broken. You're not going to
it's not going to be about who I vote in
or who I vote out. Okay, that model is
broken. And you know, and as long as the
people just stay there and they think
somehow some leader is going to change
it, I don't think that's going to
happen. You know, I I just it's just uh
historically, how does change happen?
man, it happens through a revolt. No one
who's in power is going to actually
willingly go, "Okay, you guys made a
good point. I'm out of here. Here you
go. I'm I'm giving you the reigns of
power." And so I think but at but at the
same time I believe there's this been
ongoing kind of de emasculation
of men especially when you look around
you know this whole transgender and you
know emasculation of men and empowerment
of women whatever you may think it is on
the surface. I'm starting to think that
one of the reasons is to really take
down the natural people who are in
charge, men, the ones who can make a
change. Okay? You take them down, you
emasculate them, you make sure they act
like women, and then you empower the
women who never will be a threat. And
now you can control a society. And so I
think that a lot that is one of the
ingredients because after despite what
I've just said about there has to be
some sort of revolt in some way. Today's
your western man can't revolt. you know,
I mean, I'm sure there's little pockets,
but I'm saying by and large, you know,
these are the people who are like, you
know, they cringe at, you know, the
wrong word.
These aren't people who are going to
make a change. And I think that is
intentional. It was intentional to weak
them and turn them into spineless
jellyfish who just care about their, you
know, hedonistic pleasures. Um, and now
you can easily control them. So, long
story short, yeah, it's going to get a
lot worse before it can happen. And by
the way, speaking to your point about
the feminization, I've mentioned uh on,
you know, several shows and I actually
have a section in my in my forthcoming
book where I talk about what many uh
Muslim men have told me that the West is
akin to a woman to be mounted,
right? But right, you you f her. You
>> I've heard that too.
>> You mount her.
>> The western mind,
>> she wants it. The West wants it.
>> Exactly. does she doesn't the western
mind doesn't understand that this is
what I call a lack of cultural theory of
mind right you and I could not
understand each other because we don't
speak a common language I I may speak
English and you only speak Mandarin that
might be but we could speak both the
same language but we don't have the same
cultural reference points right so so in
the west kindness generosity magnanimity
bene
is called weakness weakness, weakness,
weakness.
>> It's called You're inviting me to attack
you.
>> You're inviting me to f you and your
children and your women. You're a punk,
right? So, it's I mean I I presume that
you've had access to at least I mean I'm
Canadian, you're American. You've had
access to American politicians. Yes.
>> Uh yeah. Yeah. In limited ways.
>> Do they do do any of them get it? Like,
do you get You don't have to mention
names if you don't want to, but I mean,
do some of them say, "I get it. I'm on
it." Or are they all bathing in the pool
of suicidal empathy?
>> No. No. I've been around many who say,
"I get it." But I think they're just
saying whatever they have to say to get
out of the meeting and then they move on
with their normal, you know, you know,
whatever they think. Um, they're being
diplomatic, in other words, and they
don't want to look stupid. Um, but the
point that you're saying, which I'd
really like to emphasize, uh, which is,
and the irony is the more here's the
here's the western mind. The more
Muslims lash out, the more that's proof
we did something wrong and we have to
appease them.
>> The worse it gets, the more we have to
become doormats. And yet, the more you
become a doormat, that just in in
enrages them more to attack you. So,
it's like an insane circle.
>> I I tell you I'll tell you a great story
that speaks exactly to the point that
you just said. Uh so I think it was 2013
I had been invited to give a couple of
uh lectures in Oslo, Norway. And so the
the host who who picks me up at the
airport is a Norwegian man, a white guy,
Norwegian guy. And as I get to the
airport, I noticed it's filled with
Somali hijabed women. And so I sort of
turn to him. I say, "Wow, I didn't I
didn't quite expect uh Oslo to be
Mogadishu. Uh how is it going with the
integration of the noble peaceful
Somali?" And he he looks at me and I
could almost predict. He goes, "Oh, it's
it's it's really not going well." I say,
"Oh, yeah. How is that? Is that does
that surprise you? Is it did you think
otherwise would happen in Norway because
there is such cultural uh similarity
between the Somali and the Norwegians?
uh he said no I think we've really
failed in our ability to provide them
with a hospitable and so for the next 5
minutes he explained to me that yes the
Somali and other Muslim immigrants were
there was m major problems in Norway but
the clear conclusion of that is that it
had absolutely nothing to do with them
and it demonstrated how shitty the
Norwegians were boom
>> yeah absol absolutely that's exactly And
and then that's why the worse the their
behavior, the more appeasement, you
know, and I and and again, you know,
you're you're the psychologist, but it's
uh how the western mind is thinking is
just it's just baffling. And here's
another, you know, another point I've
been dwelling on. You know, you know,
the white as in Norwegian, Nordic,
European sort of um population of the
world is something like I don't know 3
to 6% of the world, okay, of the world.
And yet this is the one group that has
to let everyone in, that has to suppress
its culture, its religion, its heritage,
that has to shut up. What I mean, what
I' I often say jokingly, but maybe it's
not a joke. I'd like to start seeing,
you know, preservation parks for white
people where they can roam before they
totally become extinct. I mean, think
about it. This is 36%, okay? And yet
you're treating the 96% as if they're
the ones that you you're you're And it's
also arrogant because it suggests like
I'm so powerful. I don't have to worry
about numbers, you know, but it's like
you are just and and then the birth rate
is nothing. It's negative and the Muslim
birth rate is quadrupling,
>> you know, in in in Europe. This just
it's it's just so baffling. I've never
seen anything like it.
>> So here, so we were talking now about
sort of the politicians, you know, being
suicidally empathetic and so on, but
let's kind of bring in the dynamics of
Christians. So you're you're Coptic
Christians. I think uh Egypt has 10%
Coptic Christians. Correct.
>> Yeah, they say anywhere between 10 and
15.
>> Okay. Exactly. And of course, once upon
a time, it was all Coptic Christians.
Gee, I wonder what happened to to those
numbers.
>> Well, they saw the light of Islam and
just converted in droves
>> peacefully. Peacefully. Right. Exactly.
Uh Iraqi Christians, what happened to
them? Syrian Christians, what happened
to them? In my own lifetime, I grew up
in Lebanon. Lebanon used to be a
Christian majority country. within my
lifetime it is now substantially Muslim
majority country and on and on and on.
Now the reason why I'm setting this up
is because when I often receive messages
from Western Christians, they will these
are rabid Jew haters. What they will say
to me is that the the real problem is
not Islam. Like they're they're huge
Christian lovers, their Christian
identity, but the real problem is that
they hate the Jew. Let me give you one
or two examples. If I post the names of
uh the grooming gang rapists in Britain
across 40 different cities in Britain.
Let me just summarize their names for
you. Muhammad Ahmed Muhammad Ahmed
Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad Muhammad
Muhammad Ahmed Muhammad Hussein Hussein
Ali Muhammad and when I Mustafa Exactly
Mahmood once in a while we change it. We
change the variation of the spelling of
Muhammad. Sometimes it's with one M,
sometimes it's with two M. Sometimes
with it's E, sometimes it's with a.
>> When I say sarcastically, of course, I
I'm not smart enough to be able to see
any unifying link across these noble,
peaceful, undocumented love makers. Is
there any is there anybody who could
help me with this? I will get thousands
of responses. Yes, effing Jew. It's the
Jews who did this. So I So then I write
back and I say, "Wait, hold on. I just
want to make sure. Three Muhammads
gangraded a girl in Rockdale. It's due
to the Jews." How? By the way, Raymond,
do you know how it is due to the Jews?
>> No.
>> It's because who let them in? Did you
not know that the immigration policy in
Italy, in Sweden, in Norway, in France,
in Britain, in Spain, in Canada, all of
the immigration policies of those
countries, the real architects behind it
are the Jews. So, sure, you could be an
Islamophobe and blame and blame the
Muhammads for the gang rapes, about
250,000 in in Britain alone, but the
real culprit is the Jew. Now, the ones
who are levying that message to me are
not Muslims from Al Ahar. They're guys
who've got in their bio, Christ is king.
So, how can you win a war against Islam
when we supposedly the Jews and the
Christians have a common quote enemy and
yet you're turning on the Jew as your
real enemy?
>> I mean, look, the bottom line is facts
are facts. And if you want to believe
that, let's say the Jews are in control
of every European country's politics,
okay, fine, believe that. But you know
what? That then that leads to another
question. What does that say about you
and your leaders, the the native
inhabitants? Okay, that makes you extra
pathetic, doesn't it? Go fix that. Okay,
if if that if you in other words, what
are the Jews all powerful gods? If
that's the case, go fix it if you really
think that's the case. Right.
>> Well, we can fix it. We kill all of
them. That's why Hitler was I mean prove
it first of all and you know put a put
one of your own actual national uh
leaders let them be in charge but when I
even look at other leaders you know
Victor Orban of Hungary who's doesn't
conform to that formula uh he actually
likes the Jews in Israel. Okay. So it's
what's there to say you know it's it's
it's one more of the scapegoat kind of
thing. Uh who is you just mentioned it.
Who's doing the raping? Is it the Jews
or is it the Mustafas and the Muhammad
and the M? Okay. So, kind of it's just I
and it it may be another way, you know,
how we just said the appeasement. Okay.
Kind of like instead of confronting
reality, I blame myself. Well, now I
also blame the Jew. So, let's blame
anyone and everyone except the problem.
You see what I'm saying?
>> Exactly.
>> Because that's acceptable. But to say,
and again, I think a lot of this has to
do uh you know, a lot of Jews look
white, right? I mean, they're white kind
of. You're whatever. I don't know. I
don't know how to explain it, but a lot
of European Jews are white-l lookinging.
So, I think there's this also idea of
race. You know, the Europeans are so
terrified of the word race, racism, and
if you accuse them of race, being a
racist. So, you know, if you're brown
and you're a Muhammad, I'm not going to
I'm not going to say anything against
you. Okay? Uh but a Jew, I mean, they
look white. They're kind of European.
I'll attack them because
>> Jeffrey Epstein was Jewish. So, it's not
true that the rapists were Muslim
because Jeffrey Epste is Jewish.
No, but I mean, you know, I say this as
if I'm joking, but I literally receive
thousands of these a day. I mean,
yesterday I posted a tweet which is now
pinned on my profile where I genuinely
said, it was very hard for I said, you
know, I've been doing this for over
three decades. And yes, I've received
millions of lovely messages from people,
but I also receive unbelievable threats
and insults and harassment. that, you
know, I I've taken now a 2-year leave
from my home university because of all
of the threats and all the difficulties
that I face in Montreal, which is
turning into another European reality.
And so, I was thinking at one point, is
it all worth it? I mean, I've done more
than my fair share. I've done more than
what a thousand people will do in 50
lifetimes because it almost seems
impenetrable. You want to wake up every
day, Raymond, ready to take on the new
fight. But it seems as though if you
have your own people, I mean you have
Jews which I call wood cricket Jews. Do
do you know this expression I use? Wood
cricket. You know what? So the wood wood
cricket it it comes from my the
parasitic word. The wood cricket abhores
water. It it wants nothing to do with
water.
>> Yeah.
>> When it is parasitized by a hairworm, a
type of neuroparasite. The the hairworm
needs the wood cricket to jump and
commit suicide into water in order to
complete its reproductive cycle. So when
I see Jews with signs, Jews for Hamas,
Jews for Palestine, I mean, you really
are a wood cricket. And so now that's
become known. This is kind of one of
those gadism terms, wood cricket Jew. So
how can I fight against this enemy out
there when the people within my tribe,
to your earlier point, are turning their
hatred towards their own tribe rather
than to guys who want to rape them.
And you know what it also though
indirectly also proves your point
because the problem I think is okay
people are angry at let's say the
government of Israel but then somehow
that becomes all Jewish people
>> but as you just pointed out there's Jews
who actually hate the government of
Israel. So you know to put them all as a
monol with in a collective again in and
of itself that's problematic. I mean I
understand your main point is that
there's Jews who are against you. Okay.
But that just proves that you can't talk
about the Jews because the Jews have
diverse views and it's just unfortunate
this kind of, you know, you know, that
people conflate. Okay. Oh, I'm not happy
with Netanyahu. Therefore, the Jews rule
and run the world and they're evil. You
know, it's that's, you know, the it's a
fallacy. You're jumping from a premise
to a false conclusion. And um but yeah,
we're we're we're in a day and age, Gad,
where there's a lot of stupidity. Okay.
as I think you know I mean you give it
more euphemistic terms and scientific
jargon around it but to me it's just
stupidity uh abject stupidity and uh
it's and it's ultimately what's behind
so much of what we're seeing
>> the only thing I would say is that
stupidity might be that I don't have a
high IQ or I don't know basic I don't
know that Fran France is in Europe you
know I I lack knowledge this is unique
in that it's diabolical because this
stupidity is a flesh eating bacteria. It
eats.
>> You're right. It is It is a virus and it
is parasitic. Uh I'm I'm just trying to
use layman terms. You know, I appreciate
that.
>> Boiled down. They're just stupid. But
you're right. I mean, there's obviously
a nuanced understanding to why and how.
But in the end, I just like to look at
results and you know, whe whether, like
I said, whether you're evil or you're
just dumb, you're going to you do you
end up doing the same thing. So, it's
that thing that we have to deal with,
whatever the purpose or whatever the
origin. What do you think of your uh
compatriate, Egyptian compatriate who
apparently people say that he looks like
me, not I look like him, he looks like
me, the vile
or giastically ogre Basim Yousef. What
are your thoughts on him?
>> Basim Ysef comedian. He's the comedian
who used to be a physician and who now
spends his entire life uh going on shows
saying how evil the Jews and then of
course he catches. No, no, I mean
Israeli. He's not Jews. I love Jews. I
have a friend who's a Jewish. Uh but he
the the Palestinian the the Palestinian
people are beautiful. Right. Allah
why do they hate us? Right? So, you just
bombed and killed and raped 1,200 people
Allah. Right? This is a very sort of
Arabic form of lamentation, right? I
strike you and then I I scream to God,
why do you hate me so as I put out calls
for your genocidal extermination?
If you don't know anything about him,
then we we move on. But
>> no, no, actually, I don't know what he
said, but you've told me what he said,
and I'd like to comment about something.
>> Sure. um which is okay so here's the
thing about Islam here's what I here's
how you know again I have a very sort of
you know holistic look on things and I
don't really pay you know to what's
happening in the moment but the the
general broad overview with pal the
Palestinians and Israel for me is this
Islam has proven itself time and time
again okay to not be able to live at
peace with its non-Muslim neighbors okay
you probably remember Samuel Huntington
and his clash of
>> bloody bloody borders Yeah. And he's
absolutely right. Okay. Uh so this is
this is the you know the first premise.
Okay. The only way you're going to live
side by side with Muslims is you are
subject subjugated to them in a vile
way. Okay. You're a second class demi or
whatever mistreated. Okay. And in worst
case scenario they treat you like the
Jews. Okay. Um so that is a fact. We
can't get around that. Now on the one
hand do I like seeing Palestinian women
and children just being killed? No I
don't. On the other hand, I understand
the situation, which is that the
Israelis know that there can be no peace
no matter how the Palestinians act and
what they say. So, it's kind of like
everyone's in a they're stuck between a
rock and a hard place. If I play the the
game that the West plays and appease,
then I get slow encroaching Islam
beating me slowly. So, I have to take
the harsh way, you know, or what appears
to be a very kind of harsh decisive way.
So what I would say, what I'm trying to
say is to their credit, the Jews and the
Israelis know Islam. They understand it
and they're not going to do what the
West does, which is appease it and try
to play the nice guy. They understand,
you know, there's that saying, uh, you
know, where I think it's like the Arabs
either at your throat or at your foot. I
mean, that is somewhat historically
accurate. Okay? And I would change it
from Arab to Muslim in general. Uh,
because that is the historical
manifestation of Islam. It never once
lived at peace with its neighbor when it
could have attacked. Sure. When it was
weak, it didn't. When it was weaker than
its neighbor, when it's strong.
>> Yeah. And I mean, it's a central tenant.
When you are weak, cry victim. When you
are strong, show no mercy.
>> I'm going to tell you a very funny
anecdote. I've been sharing it which you
you might when I worked at the library
of congress speaking of u somales uh
there was a lot of them there and you
know diplomat that I was despite what I
was doing I was very friendly with them
and we'd speak Arabic because you know
they speak Arabic and one of them was
like their sheh he was he was like the
wise elder and he knew the you know he
knew Islam but every time we'd talk kind
of have little debates you know during
lunch um and I would mention kind of
verses he he would try to pull the you
know Islam is peace right but I but at
the same time he has the head. Yeah,
this is a Salafi. Okay. So one time I I
I explained to him the breakdown as I
understand it of the
right the abrogating verses and the
abregated verses in the Quran which for
those who don't understand basically the
idea is there's a lot of contradiction
in the Quran and what Muslim jurists do
is uh they look at what came later right
so the Mecca Quran which is when
Muhammad was weak outnumbered it's the
older version that's where you get the
peaceful verses right uh you have your
faith I have my faith there's no
compulsion in your religion etc. And
then once Muhammad becomes powerful in
Medina and goes on the war path that's
now where you get a right Quran 95 you
know fight kill belleaguer them wherever
you find them fight the people of the
book until they pay tribute feel humbled
etc etc now the other thing so
abrogation means you go by the newest
right because it was situational but it
also means that if you as a Muslim find
yourself in a situation that's closer to
the mechan versus you should act on them
okay and the mechan verses again are
you're outnumbered you're weak So I I
laid this all out to this, right? And he
he tried to dissemble, right? And I kept
saying, "Yeah, but the the Medina verses
are violent and but the Mecca verses
when you're when you're outnumbered,
yeah, you should say what you're
saying." And he finally got frustrated
and said, "Yeah, I'm living in Mecca.
I'm in DC."
Exa Exactly. Exactly. Well, but that So
two points here I want to make. I want
to talk about reformation if at all
possible. I think not, but let's see
what you think. And number two, to the
point of when you're in the minority or
not, I've always said, although it's not
my maxim, demography is destiny, right?
I mean, the greatest danger is just a
numbers game. When they are 1% and 2%,
ah, it's not a big problem. They're
lovely. They just wear cool saratoral
scarves and who cares? It's just a
scarf. Wh why are you such a bigot,
Professor Sad, taking pictures of behi
from behind women that are fully veiled?
It's just a cloth, right? I mean, yes.
And the Nazi symbol is just a geometric
pattern, right? Uh so there is symbolism
meaning behind those. The more veils I
have, the worse it's going to get for
Jews. That's a law of nature. So number
one, what are your thoughts on
immigration? Can can we sustain these
levels of immigration? Are we already
too late in the game? Can these patterns
be reversed? Can Islam be compatible
with the West? I know I've posed a whole
bunch of questions. Let's start with
that and then we'll talk about
reformation.
>> Yeah, sure. So, um, you know, I'll start
off by talking again about Europe
because I think that's the most paradic
example more than Canada and US of
course. Um, but again to go back to what
I was saying about, you know, small
white percentage that just caters and
appeases and capitulates before these
hordes of non-whites. Um, just consider
what it means that in all these capitals
of Western Europe, Oslo, you were in
Norway, I think Brussels, I wrote an
article and I think I had like eight
capitals. The number one newborn baby
boy named Muhammad.
>> Okay.
>> And I mean what? Imagine this. Would
this ever happen and fly in any other
civilization? Could you imagine India
the number one name is uh you know
Michael
>> forgive me for interrupting you and I'm
gonna seed the floor to you. Imagine in
any of the 56 Islamic countries in the
OIC the number one name is Moshe.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. What would what
would that ever happen? Is that even
conceivable in the mythical world? And
even more important should it be? I know
we would say no because that's your
land. that's your country, that's your
heritage, you should have your names and
your people be the dominant ones. Okay.
And so that we're seeing this happening
in Europe again underscores just the
absurd insanity. But as far as as you
know, the demographics are destiny.
Absolutely. And I've seen polls, you
know, pew polls that say something like
Germany in 2050 or60 it's going to be
something like 40% Muslim. At that
point, game over. Okay? because it's
we've already established that the
German man is not much of a man. No
offense to those few ones who are, but
by and large they've been so
emasculated, right? Uh so that yeah, if
it's four to four Muslims to 10 German
men, you're done. It's over. Okay. Um
it's already almost over seeing what's
happening. So yeah, absolutely.
Demographics is destiny. It's really bad
in Europe. Canada, you can speak better
about that than I can. in the US, you
know, it's still a small number.
Muslims, I think, are one to 2% and
maybe half of them are blacks who
convert in in prison. I understand,
right? Um, but that doesn't, you know,
that doesn't make it all the better. I
mean, it's better to nip it in the bud.
And so now the question becomes, well,
but isn't that racist? And, you know,
why would you not allow Muslims? And it
just simply comes down to their belief
system, which is so well documented,
which is not open to debate. Okay? It's
I always give these analogies and I'll
give you okay let me just pause that and
explain what the moderate what what a
moderate Muslim is okay visav the
radical the analogy I give is this okay
um you know Nazism right think of Nazism
Nazism is an ideology and it's
supremacist just like Islam right it's
it's racially supremacist
and yet we have a Nazi who was a ranking
Nazi Oscar Schindler who helped Jews
right and other undesirabs and he saved
him at no small risk to himself, right?
But he was a Nazi. So what do we make of
that? Does that mean that he was, you
know, he believed in the tenets of
Nazis, you know, national socialism, but
when it came to, you know, being a
monster and killing innocent people, his
humanity rose above it, and at least he
didn't do that part. Or shall we argue
that no, he was following a moderate
form of Nazism. I've never heard the
latter. Nobody ever says that, and
rightfully so, because that's stupid.
But when we talk about, you know,
so-called moderate Muslims, this is the
game we like to play. The the fact is
Islam like Nazism is black and white,
supremacist, violent and intolerant.
Okay? I mean, we can get into the verses
and then what Sharia says, etc., etc. It
is that. Okay? So, you need to
understand this is what a moderate
Muslim is. He's the one that actually
doesn't conform to it. He's he's the
aberration. He's not a representative of
I don't care how many they are. He is
not representing a true Islam just like
Oscar Schindler doesn't didn't represent
true Nazism. Okay, but we never do that.
We play this game as if oh no the
moderate represents true Islam and then
these radicals they're a fringe. The
reality is no, the radicals are the ones
who actually practice the true Islam.
And so this is might bring all this up
to go back to the demographic and you
know immigration issue in that it's this
is the religion. So when you bring it in
and you say, "Well, we live in a society
that believes in freedom and religious
liberty and women parading around in,
you know, bikinis and then you bring in
this mentality, okay, what do you expect
is going to happen? How can you how
dense can people be?" Of course, what
you see happening in Europe, the the
rape gangs in in England, in Sweden,
which went from having virtually no
crimes to being the rape capital of the
world, uh, all thanks to Muslim
migrants. Of course, that's to be
expected. you're you can't mix oil and
water together. Um, and it's an
ideological question. Now, again, this
isn't a racial question. I'm not saying,
oh, if you're if you're ethnically
Muslim, then you should stay out. It's
an ideological. You could be white and
believe that and need to stay out, too.
So, you know, governments and countries
are more than happy to say, "Oh, if you
believe in a certain ideology, we don't
want you here." But we don't do that
with Islam, even though it's so
straightforward. Not only is it
straightforward, but its entire history
is a manifestation of the violence that
it teaches. So it's I don't know what
the debate is about.
>> Yeah. So in in chapter 7 of the
parasitic mind, I have a whole section
where I talk about uh so forgive me. I'm
it's going to be a mouthful, but I'll
explain it. Uh nomological networks of
cumulative evidence. And this is a a
framework whereby if I want to convince
you of something, I'll get you data from
across time periods, across cultures,
across methodologies. In other words,
what I'm doing is I'm bringing in
distinct lines of evidence, all of which
triangulate to prove that my position is
right. Well, if I were to build a
nomological network of cumulative
evidence
in in asking the question, is Islam a
religion of peace or not, it would
almost be impossible for me to come up
with a greater set of unequivocal data
that offers a clear answer that it isn't
right. So which which religion is most
likely to have converts after they
convert commit uh terror attacks out of
all the religions that exist? Which
religion is most likely to treat
minorities the worst historically? Which
religion has led to the greatest amount
of deaths in its entirety? Uh what do
the cannons of the religion say? You
probably are you familiar with Bill
Warner? Do you know who that is?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So Bill Warner for the for
the listeners who may not know he's he's
by training he's a physicist. He was a
professor of physics but then later in
his career he founded the center for the
study of political Islam. And so he took
a scientific method content analysis and
used it to study the contents of the key
texts of Islam. Whether it be the Hadith
or the Quran or the Sah the biography of
Muhammad. You could study its content to
see does it largely preach brotherly
love and love for the Jews or not.
Right? And so the the or how about d uh
databases for terror attacks since 9/11
alone 47,000 plus terror attacks in
nearly 70 countries by one religion.
Does that suggest that it's peaceful or
not? But as long as you could come up
with one convenient store owner named
Ahmed who is a very loving and peaceful
guy that you're friends with and you
play soccer with on Sunday, then that is
the real representation of Islam. Unless
>> not only that,
>> not only that, but all those extreme
high and disproportionate number of
terrorist attacks ultimately prove how
the grievances that Muslims have because
they're being mistreated.
>> Exactly.
>> So you need to work harder at it.
>> Exactly. Right. Okay. So let I promised
that we would get to reformation. So if
we can't get the western politicians to
change their minds, if we can't get the
average westerner to not succumb to
paracetize thinking and suicidal
empathy, could could there be a
reformation project like has happened in
other religions whereby Islam in 50 to
100 years is largely the spiritual
element and all of the political stuff
ceases to exist and now we can all get
along. Is this possible or am I speaking
nonsense?
>> No, I don't think it I mean look,
anything's possible. Any you know
there's uh you know gay Muslims, there's
Muslims eat pork. So you can always have
a group of people who say I'm a
representative of this religion and they
can do whatever they want, right? Um but
as a as you know as an actual movement
in fact I've when it comes to the
Protestant Reformation or just the
reformation in general I've I very much
about you know as as an analogy and I've
argued that in fact what we're seeing in
the modern era is a reformation of Islam
that very much follows the Protestant
Reformation. But because the core texts
the Bible versus Islamic scriptures are
so antithetical we're seeing
antithetical results. And so allow me to
unpack that briefly. Uh you know the
Protestant Reformation at its core is
basically a rejection of centuries of
tradition ecclesiastical authority and
just go into the scriptures right solar
scripture the bible by itself. Okay and
this was very much aided by the printing
press I mean they were cod of reminisce
and people could not read and so that
happened. Now what what happened
recently you have most people don't
understand but historically you know
your average Muslim and your average
Arab is illiterate. Okay, you didn't
have printed books of the Quran. At
best, you had one sheh who maybe has it
and you know he preaches from it etc.
But now in the Islamic world it's very
much like what what is happening in
let's say 16th century Europe where they
do not just the printing press, they
have the internet. Now anyone can access
not just the Quran in any language.
Okay? You know historically if you were
non-Arabic reader you had to read the
Quran in Arabic and not even know what
you were reading and just recite it by
route. Okay, which was I guess was a
good thing. Um but now it's translated
in all these other languages. You can
read the the hadith okay which is very
violent the s of Muhammad the teles etc
is now available for everyone. So to me
much of what is called salifism or
wahhabiism
which they trace to uh you know abdah
from uh late 1700s who's called a
reformer of Islam. So what did he do? He
sort of did the same thing. He basically
said hey there's been a lot of
aggressions into Islam. We need to get
get them all out and we need to go
straight to the written texts. Okay, the
Quran and the Sunnah as captured in the
hadith etc. And what happens when you
look at those? Well, you become you
become ISIS. Okay. U so this is a
perfect example of that. You know, for
the Protestant Reformation could have
turned out it did turn out good because
okay, you know, whatever you did, you
ejected Catholicism, but at least you're
based on the Bible. And the Bible
teaches what? monogamy, you know, uh,
loving your neighbor, uh, you know, all
the good stuff. All right? Whereas in
Islam, kill the apostate, have four
wives, have sex slaves. Okay? So, it
makes sense that. So, in a way, I always
say the protest, the reformation of
Islam is sort of unfolding. I think
what's needed in what you might be
referring to is not a pro reformation,
it's an enlightenment, which is a little
different. And enlightenment would be
more of, you know, kind of like, all
right, we've had enough of what this
stuff says and we still want to maintain
our culture and our heritage, so we need
to clean it up and kind of get rid of
one example is there's a there's a group
that's called the Quranists.
>> And what they want to do, they basically
say only the Quran counts, which of
course is a radical idea because for
Sunnis, the twin pillars are the Quran
and the Hadith as the Sunnah. Um, so and
if and if they could do that, of course
they're considered heretics. But if you
do that, sure, you got rid of a lot of
problems. Okay? Because I would I mean
the Quran itself is, as you probably
know, it's very poetic. It's very
ambiguous. Of course, the the the teac
and the exedites usually give the you
know very negative spins and a lot of it
is negative. But if you can actually get
rid of the hadith, okay, that yeah, that
that would be a great step forward. Uh
you could become that that would go
handinhand with a sort of enlightenment
of Islam. But again, they are considered
heretics and they're not even 1% of the
Muslim moral.
>> Yeah. So, Imam Tawhidi, who's a friend
of mine, I don't know if you know him,
the Australian uh cleric, uh who's
actually when you hear him speak, you
would fall in love with Islam because he
he he seems to support all of the
secular values that you and I would
support. I think he would argue exactly
what you just said, which is stick to
the Quran, forget forget the hadith. But
here's an idea I have. So a and I don't
know how you would do this canonically.
Earlier you mentioned abrogation and
again let me repeat it for the folks who
don't know what this is. Uh you've got
you've got two passages in the Quran
that says A and not A. Meaning there's a
contradiction perfect contradiction. The
later verse abrogates the earlier verse.
God can change his mind. It's
situational. He used to think A. Now he
thinks it's not A. Is there a way for us
to find discover maybe the the head of
Alazar University in Egypt or whether it
be the crown prince of Saudi Arabia
discover a new supra abrogation wand
that says everything that was violent is
now abrogated because for some of the
purists Islamic scholars who need to
base their world view in the cannons of
the text you need to find a mechanism
ism to abrogate all that stuff.
Otherwise, even with the enlightenment
that you're speaking of, if I am a
purist, I go back to my book and I say,
"No, no, no. I've got to kill the
bastard Jews."
>> So, I is that even feasible or is that
science fiction?
>> Tell you what I'm familiar with and what
I've seen. One argument that some of the
reformers have tried to make about the
Quran is they say that um okay, you
know, there are violent verses, but they
were meant for that time in that place.
They're not meant to apply to us. What's
interesting about that argument is I've
actually used that argument to exonerate
the Old Testament, the Jewish
scriptures. So, as you know, a lot of
people play this equivalency game and uh
they say, "Oh, the Quran's full of
violence." Well, look at, you know, the
Jewish scriptures. They got genocide and
Joshua. Yeah. And my response to that is
you're you're right. Of course, the Old
Testament is very violent and bloody,
but it's not in used in open-ended
language. You're supposed to Yeah. fight
and kill Jebusites and Hebusites, etc.
These are people that don't exist
anymore. Right.
>> Exactly.
>> If you look at the Islamic uh the Quran,
it's not like that. It doesn't say fight
the Per the Persians. It doesn't say
fight the Byzantines or the Romans. It
says fight the Kaf the infidels. That is
open-ended language. Infidels are still
alive and kicking. It's us, the
non-Muslims.
>> So, that has always been, you know, you
can do this mechanism uh with the Jewish
scriptures because I think they're very
they're temporal. A lot of what God is
saying was for those people living at
that time. And I'm sure other people
would argue, but at least they have
names. He doesn't say fight Gentiles,
right? He says fight these particular
people,
>> whereas Islam doesn't do that. So my
point is yeah that could have been a
mechanism and a lot of Muslims try to
argue for that but the the reason it
doesn't work is for the reason I gave
because the lang and the language the
it's it doesn't say you know so Quran
9:29 right fight the people of the book
yeah
>> until they pay tribute Jiza and feel
themselves subdued so look at how
open-ended it is who are the people of
the book Christians and Jews and when do
you keep fighting them until they pay
tribute and are subdued Well, there's a
lot of Christians and Jews who are not
paying tribute and who are not subdued.
Therefore, the verse still applies.
That's why I honestly think, and this is
why I really I I respect apostates more
than the people who play the moderate
Islam game. I understand why the latter
do what they're doing. You know, they
don't want to rock the boat. Maybe they
don't want to get killed. But when you
become an apostate, it's you've reached
the point where you finally said, "Look,
this is I can't this can't be
rehabilitated or salvaged. All right, I
I got to go." But if you try to if you
try to do the whole, you know, I want to
use an enlightened form. Yeah, you can
do it. I said as an individual, you can
do whatever and you can believe
whatever. But is it going to catch on?
Is it going to be part of the Islamic
world? Highly unlikely.
>> Well, and and I mean the Quran states it
is the final inherent word of God. So
that already removes the reformation.
It's perfect. Every every syllable,
every every letter is perfect. and uh
and the gates of Ishted shut down.
>> Shut down. Exactly.
>> In the 10th or 11th century.
>> I'm asking you here to look into the
hearts of individual Muslims. And you
may or may not be able to do so, but
there are roughly about two billion
Muslims, many of whom are perfectly
lovely and kind and gentle and peaceful,
but yet they decide that they're going
to say, "I am a proud Muslim,"
notwithstanding all of the information
that we have. Is it because they don't
know the truth about their religion or
is it they know the truth about their
religion but they're doing what I call
cafeteria Islam which is I pick the
parts that I like and I ignore because
otherwise why would you choose to
associate I mean if if I knew right now
that Judaism I'm not very religious but
I'm very much steeped in my Jewish
heritage because there's a very earthly
component to being Jewish. It's part of
a shared people just like Egyptian
Coptic Christians are a real people with
a lineage. Now you may believe some of
the religious doctrines or not, but
you're still a Coptic Christian. Are
most of them being Muslim in the way
that I am Jewish or do they believe all
this stuff in their books?
>> Believe it or not, I actually think the
former I think and and it and it almost
makes it more dangerous. And so here
here's what I'm saying. Um, and this is
one of the weaknesses I believe, you
know, those that the anti- jihadist
movement or whatever they, you know,
however they're presented is they're,
you know, they're sticklers about what
the Quran says. You know, the Quran says
this verse and then they act like
because the Quran says this, every
Muslim's brain does that. Okay. And
that's not realistic. Okay. Of course,
the radicals, the fundamentalists, the
copies, yeah, they do that. But the vast
majority don't. But on the other hand,
you know, it's what you touched on
earlier, which is, you know, they're
proud of their heritage and they're not
going to, you know, even no matter what
they know about it or what they don't
know about it. This is us and, you know,
Arab pride and Arab honor. We're not
going to throw our, we're not Westerners
who spit on our ancestors, no matter
what they did, we're going to praise
them. We're going to elevate them and
we're going to venerate them. Okay? I
think that's that's the Muslim. That's
actually that's most people outside of
the west I think which is its own
interesting and curious topic. Um but so
I think a lot of Muslims it's more you
know it's cultural it's this is our
heritage this is our people and if I to
criticize them you're criticizing me
okay because of that you know that whole
lineage that I'm
right it's not again this is one of
those sort of um disconnects that
westerners don't understand of how
Muslims think. Um, so I think a lot of
so for example, let's say, you know,
anger or hatred towards Israel. It's not
because they're quoting the Quran. You'd
be s surprised. Uh, ISIS goes out of its
way to say, "No, no, it's not time to
hit Israel now. We have to, you know,
take out Assad or do this." But your
average Muslim who probably doesn't know
the Quran, he's the one that's so angry
because it's a pride thing. You're, you
know, our people, our Muslims. Um and
again so that's why I say maybe even
more tenacious than you know just being
a literalist who okay the Quran says
this and I'm gonna enact it. Uh it just
it gives them the sort of you know
extreme tenacity to just follow be part
of the team part of the um part of the
tribe that is against everyone else.
>> It's going to be tough to conquer this
problem. Uh what are some projects as we
come towards the end? Of course I could
speak to you for five hours but I don't
want to keep you too long. Uh
>> thank you. Uh what what are some
projects that you're currently working
on other than of course please mention
your forthcoming book to us so that
people
>> sure well that's the one which I'm I'm
dotting the eyes in literally I just
finished some maps and I'm now trying to
select pictures but the book is written
uh the it's called the the two swords of
Christ the um five centuries of war
between Islam and the warrior monks of
uh christryendom and why why I wrote
that it's basically a trilogy my other
books sword and scimitar and defenders
of the west they all complement one one
another uh but this book you know and
why I called it the two swords of Christ
uh you know it's a pun you may be
familiar with Jesus um you know there's
a verse in Luke where he actually says
you sell your garment and buy a sword
and then the disciples say here Lord
there's two swords right here and he
says that's enough okay now medieval
Christians understood it in a certain
way which I'll get to but modern
Christians have totally allegorized it
means absolutely nothing okay he's not
talking in any way shape or form of
defense okay but to medieval Christians
What it meant is and which I find
interesting is that two swords aren't
enough because one is against spiritual
forces which modern day Christians agree
with and one is against physical human
forces which they don't
>> and uh that's actually how it was
understood and so I called the book two
swords of Christ because that was the
rationale for the military orders and
the two groups the main ones that I
write about the templars and the
hospitalers were basically the two
swords they saw themselves as that. So I
find all that kind of thinking very
refreshing and I find a lot of Europeans
also u because I want to inspire them
and remind them you're you don't have to
always be a doormat. You can stand up
for your culture. The irony of what
we're seeing in Europe today is it's the
antithesis of what Europe we didn't talk
about history and we could have um maybe
at another time but
>> sure few few people understand that you
know in the 7th century if you looked at
Christendom the bulk of it was what we
today call the Muslim world. It was in
North Africa, Egypt, Syria all the way
to the Megh, Morocco, greater Syria, uh,
Asia Minor, Anatolia. Okay, that was the
bulk of Christendom. And Europe was the
smaller, lesser brother. You had five
seas. Only one was Rome was in Europe.
The other four, Alexandria, Antioch,
Jerusalem, later Constantinople, all
conquered and swallowed up by Islam. So
this was stuff that people don't get.
and and and and beyond that Europe
proper continued to be bombarded century
after century until they were in Iceland
raiding for slaves and screaming Allah
Akbar in the 16th century. Okay. And so
but what did Europeans do then? They
actually fought fire with fire. And
that's why they had to come up with
these militant verses to just defend
their way of life, right? Um, and it's
so to me when I look at what they're
doing today, I quoted some German woman
uh she's some council woman I think in
Munich where she gets up and says, you
know, to all those right-wingers, I want
to say one thing in in 20 years time 50
Munich is not is going to be less German
than it is going to be Muslim. It's
going to be more Muslim. And then she
goes, and that's a good thing.
>> Yes.
>> Imagine that mentality. How do you like
how did that how was that born of the
mentality I write about? And that to me
is such a riddle.
>> Amazing. Well, I can't wait uh for your
book. I can't wait to have you back on.
I'm gonna say something in Arabic. I
hope you you understand it. Uh
>> that's it's a it's a way of sort of when
someone's working hard, you kind of say
that to them
>> and I need it. So shukranoi
come back anytime you'd